ZJ: Hi, I am ZJ.
I'm a data scientist
based in Melbourne.
I want to talk about this
package called disk.frame.
Have you ever
encountered this message?
"Cannot allocate vectors
of size" whatever.
So what is the issue here?
Well the issue is
that R trying to load
the whole data into RAM, so it
doesn't really fit sometimes.
If your data is quite large,
how do you deal with that?
In this talk, I talk
about disk.frame
but Apache Spark, via,
for example, sparklyr,
is also possible.
So how does disk.frame work?
Well, disk.frame is very simple.
It's just a folder
with many fst files.
If you're not familiar with
fst files, see this website.
Each file is called a chunk.
And basically, if your
data set is too large,
I don't have to load
everything through memory,
I just break that whole
dataset into smaller chunks
and load it chunk by chunk.
Now, once I can load
the data chunk by chunk,
I can do many things.
For example, I can operate
on the chunks in parallel.
So how do you make
use of disk.frame?
Well, the first
thing you want to do
is load some data into
the disk.frame format.
So the disk.frame package has
this convenient function called
csv_to_disk.frame.
You simply provide a
path to the CSV file
and it'll convert
that to a disk.frame.
If you have multiple CSVs, you
can just pass it a list of CSVs
or a vector of CSV paths.
Well, I want to show you a
demo using 1.8 billion rows.
So I've downloaded the
Fannie Mae dataset.
So the first thing
you should do,
when you start up disk.frame,
is run this function
called setup_disk.frame.
This will set up parallel
processing for you.
As I mentioned before, I've
created a folder with many fst
files in this directory.
So I can show you the
content of this directory.
As you can see, it's just
a bunch of fst files.
So to make use of
these fst files,
I just call this function
called disk.frame,
and I'm going to cut
the head and tail, just
like a normal data frame.
I can see things
like the end row.
So you can see, there's 1.8
billion rows in this dataset
and the CSV unzipped would
be about 200 gig in size.
So these are more functions,
number of columns,
and then the names
of the columns.
So you can operate a
disk.frame almost like
as if you have a data frame.
One of the key
features of disk.frame
is that I've implemented
the dplyr verbs.
So you can make
use of dplyr verbs
directly to manipulate the data.
So I start with the
disk.frame I created.
I run this function
called srckeep,
and this is very important.
This is actually what
makes disk.frame fast.
So a srckeep basically
tells the program
which columns to
load into memory,
because there's 31 columns.
For this particular analysis,
I only need these four columns.
So I only need to load
these four columns into RAM.
So I just filter like you
would normally do with dplyr,
do a mutate and then group_by
year, which is created here,
and do a summarize,
and finally collect.
So let's run that.
While that's running,
I will show you
what's happening with
the task manager.
Most of the CPUs
are being utilized,
and that's because it's
processing all the chunks
in that dataset in parallel.
Well, as you can see,
I've done a group_by
and created new columns in the
meantime in about one minute.
This was done on the Fannie Mae
dataset with 1.8 billion rows.
To learn more about disk.frame,
simply go to diskframe.com.
I'd like to finish
off by pointing out
a couple of things.
If you do have Spark, it's
perfectly fine to use it,
but not everyone's lucky enough
to have a Spark cluster set up.
So disk.frame, you can
use R functions directly,
even those defined by the user.
Thank you.